انتقل إلى الفيديو التالي ،
لذا ما ستلاحظه هو أننا
ذخائر متوقفة تضرب المجمع
لأولئك منكم الذين ربما رأوا
قبل وبعد صور
المجمع
، يبدو إلى حد كبير مثل موقف للسيارات
به حفر كبيرة في الوقت الحالي
كانت العملية  لقد تم التخطيط
والتنفيذ بشكل رائع لإظهار الامتداد العالمي للولايات المتحدة
والتزامنا الثابت بتدمير تنظيم الدولة وتقديم
قادته إلى العدالة
وحماية أمريكا والآخرين من
أشخاص مثل البغدادي
، كانت المهمة صعبة ومعقدة
ومداهمة تم تنفيذها بأعلى مستوى
من  الاحتراف في أرقى
تقاليد الجيش الأمريكي
نظرًا لوجود اهتمام كبير
بكلاب العمل العسكرية ،
وأردت تقديم القليل من
المعلومات الأساسية عن هذه
الصورة التالية للكلاب الجميلة ، من فضلك ودعنا
نعود للحظة
قبل أن أذهب بالفعل إلى الكلب الذي سأفعله
فقط أود أن أريكم
الصور قبل وبعد مجمع الغارة ،
يمكنك أن ترى الشكل الذي بدا عليه من قبل
ويمكنك أن ترى الطريقة التي تبدو بها
آه بالطريقة التي بدت بها بعد ذلك ، لذا من
الواضح تمامًا أن نجاح
الذخائر المواجهة التي نستخدمها
للتأكد من أنها لن تكون
ضريحًا أو لا تنسى بأي
شكل من الأشكال إنها مجرد قطعة أخرى من  الأرض
كما ترون أجرت وكالة المخابرات الدفاعية
التحليل
وقارن الحمض النووي من الرفات
المأخوذة من المجمع مع عينة في الملف
أخذت
عندما كان البغدادي في سجن معسكر بوكا
في العراق في عام 2004.